there's a lot he has not killed us
there's gonna be enough pressure on
Devlin just performing so I'm not going
to add to about talking expectations I
expect him to not kill us that's Mike
Tomlin a low bar for just don't kill us
like Mason Rudolph was hey look they won
three in a row with Rudolf after Rudolf
returned from that concussion he
suffered against the Ravens but Rudolf
was horrible against the Browns and it
was going that way against the Bengals
and Mike Tomlin pushing back against
that that pride Chris you've talked
about this third round pick devoted to
Mason Rudolph can't bench him oh we used
to third-round pick on him he's the heir
apparent to Ben Roethlisberger can't
bench him at a certain point you have to
say hey you know what the embarrassment
is offset by the fact that we found
Devlin Hodges undrafted let's go ahead
and use him that's exactly right and you
know again I always wonder and these in
these type of decisions ultimately just
Mike Tomlin is he allowed to just you
know pull the trigger or you know yank
the the carpet out underneath of a guy
like Mason Rudolph has management saying
no you got to stick with them either way
at the end of the day this is the right
move it's been the right move
yeah they went on a three game win
streak after he got the concussion and
all that but come on let's be serious we
know it wasn't because of Mason Rudolph
you know their defense was playing out
of this world it's been playing out of
this world you know they've been scoring
touchdowns setting up short fields you
know it was concerning to me in Mason
Rudolph Minh I had to see them basically
re-orchestrated offense to throw the
ball three four or five yards down the
field that's all the game plan was and
then after about 18 to 20 of those
throws all okay now we'll throw a deep
cross for 20 or 25 yards you know at the
end of the day Mason Rudolph's throwing
is an issue he's just a low-level
thrower as far as NFL standards are
concerned and Devlin Hodges you know
again not prototype but he's had a lot
of reps in college he played good in the
preseason he did what was asked of him
in that charger Sunday Night Football
game that we had here on NBC and then
you saw last week I mean when there's
opportunities he hits it he's a natural
thrower the full
Paul despite his size and I think this
is the right move as long as he does
take care of the ball he'll make a few
plays and help them win games and it's
an opportunity to audition for the
inevitable replacement of Ben
Roethlisberger whenever it may be and
his body may continue to break down not
all of these guys are gonna be playing
into their 40s Tom Brady's had to do
that avocado ice cream stuff for years
to put himself where he is Ben
Roethlisberger does not strike me as the
kind of guy who does anything to enhance
his overall health and well-being to
ensure that he's gonna play beyond 40 so
he could be sooner than later they need
a replacement and they had a long 20
years Chris between Terry Bradshaw and
Ben Roethlisberger and they finally
drafted a franchise quarterback with
that 11th overall pick in 2004 maybe
Hodges turns into their Tony Romo well
that's the last guy who was undrafted
did I remember that here and we talked
about this earlier in the week yeah
who's this Tony Romo we keep hearing
about and he ends up being one of the
best quarterbacks in the NFL maybe
Hodges is on that same trajectory yeah
well nonetheless he's gonna earn his
right to maybe be in the conversation
you're right when Ben Roethlisberger is
all done to where you know again is he
the franchise yeah he's gonna have to
prove that but he might you know at the
very worst end up being a guy that's a
bridge quarterback for a while to you
know the one thing I gotta say is you
know Mike Tomlin he coaches them tough
everybody's always scared of playing
Pittsburgh Steelers because of their
physicality and they know during
training camp is Mike Tomlin hit and I
used to go to teams after I would see
Pittsburgh in training camp and that
would be the first things where you've
been I'd go Pittsburgh you go are they
hitting and they go yep it was full
tackle I mean they were it was like
knock him down slobber hitting like so
the he brings out oh man and then Kevin
Kolbert deserves a lot of credit too I
mean he's done a phenomenal job with the
roster to where you see they don't need
a team that needs a superstar
quarterback to win games pretty good old
line has some decent receivers right now
a few of them young and up-and-coming
you know the defense the front seven as
we've talked about a lot is very special
he's mixed and matched some free agents
and some drafts in the secondary so
they're a team that doesn't necessarily
I think need a superstar at quarterback
going forward either you know they can
play kind of a well-rounded full team
game and still get a lot of w's when all
said and done you mentioned Kevin
Kolbert the GM of the team
he's been with the Steelers forever
remember he's currently on a
year-to-year around forgot his choice
and if the Carolina Panthers move on
from Marty her knee David Tepper who
previously was a minority owner of the
Steelers and as a Pittsburgh guy I could
see temper come calling for Kolbert
things get very interesting next year
and it could be a position that they
have to fill in the front office it's
going to require a lot of skill and a
lot of effort to keep loading up the
cannon with great great players but
still Chris it was 20 years with no
Super Bowl championships between
Bradshaw and Roethlisberger having that
franchise quarterback his key Hodges is
gonna get the chance to maybe grow into
that role and if they can't make him
that guy then they need to think about
getting themselves into the upper
reaches around 1 and getting an
expression or rothenburger about the to
a situation to who might be hanging
around at the end of the first round
because of his injury and Pittsburgh's
the type of team that said you know what
maybe we'll take them and just let them
sit there for a year or two and get
healthy and everything like that so that
plays into this that's I think is very
interesting too
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports